good afternoon thank you for coming
after eating lunch and having a little
nap I appreciate you waking up for me
thank you very much my name is Heather
downing really excited to be in
Copenhagen it's my first time here and
I'm from Kansas City Missouri in the
United States home of the most famous
barbecue in the United States
I will fight people however war pigs was
pretty good last night I was impressed I
mean as a Midwesterner
you guys can hold your own that was
really good so let's talk a little bit
about what we're gonna talk about today
in case any of you want to just like run
to another session okay so I I've worked
for many different clients over the
course of my career but most recently
for the past three years right before I
came to octa I worked at a marketing
company that represented some of the
largest companies in the world fourteen
fifty and so because of that I have had
some unique experiences with what it
really means to work with things
especially when you have to do them
rapidly but they still have to be
production ready to a point right there
are definitely there's a difference
between something needs to go live by
the Super Bowl because the Super Bowl
does not move a date and I need to ship
a product that we own you know there's
the difference between those two I don't
really know the split in the room so how
many of you work on a product long term
like okay
several ivi right and so the other half
of you may be do either consulting or
you have many different projects yes
okay cool
all right well for this I was given the
the task recently right before I came to
octave to work with a dotnet shop that
could not cut over to dotnet core yet
because too much of their infrastructure
was invested in 4:7 okay so this is all
going to be in for seven it's going to
be in net it's not going to be done it
standard just so you're aware that this
is what I'm going to show you because so
many of the larger companies still are
on it so it's possible that many of you
are already way in front of us but this
is just the example I'm going to give
secondly I was asked many times by
different
Jr and mid developers that it's hard to
put all the puzzle pieces together that
you can attend to talk or watch a
tutorial on a piece of what you need to
do but string them together of course
eventually is what makes the seniors and
the engineers above that right so they
just kind of wanted in in an hour you
just you can you just kind of point me
from like agency where exactly I would
be going so that's what we're going to
kind of do here for those of you who are
very high level this might be a little
bit more basic for you but I wanted to
put forth what it was actually like to
do all of this and the decisions that I
made okay so within the course of sixty
minutes or so I'm gonna see if we can
just go from file new all the way to a
working API completely host sterilizer I
want to do that this whole time the only
thing I'm not going to do is I'm going
to go ahead and do in memory for the
crud in right now because there's so
many different databases I've dealt with
over the years I mean right now post
grades is all the rage but I also just
dealt with a bunch of firebase before we
talk them into graduating to cosmos DB
so you know because they're all over the
place I thought that was less valuable
and so I'm just going to put that in
memory for now because that is a whole
nother step all right so do you have any
questions before I get started then cool
so basically you get to code along with
me this is like a fireside chat it's
also very open so you don't have like
wait until the end if you have a
question while I'm going please say
something but please understand that
this is just what I've experienced and
discovered I'm not an expert I certainly
don't work at Microsoft but this is what
I have gone through and decided that if
they needed me to build something in a
day this is kind of what I could do
pretty quickly okay
make sense excellent all right so one of
the cool things about what I get to do
is I get to see all the new things I get
to go to conferences and travel a lot I
get really excited when I go to a
session and something that could
possibly make my life easier is
presented it goes kind of like this
create this thing deploy this thing
prophet sound familiar in
no I will say that the piece of it that
they show probably really is this easy
if you do it exactly that way and you
don't deviate right but I'm going to
give you an example today so this is
kind of the objectives that we're gonna
do today all right we'll see if I can
get them all in first we're actually
going to start with what you should do
which is create a repository I know
that's not usually what the tutorial
show but I'm going to do that today
then we create the project okay or
sometimes if you want to go ahead and
allow visual studio to do that for you
you can do them both at the same time
sometimes you don't always have that
option but here you go then we're just
going to deploy it with a quick publish
okay yes this is the famous right click
publish because it's important to show
that you can at least get a
proof-of-concept out there rapidly I'm
asked often can you just show somebody
they just want to see it or they just
want to see the data coming through real
quick and that is something that
sometimes happens before you land a
contract on a very large project okay so
that is sometimes done then we make some
changes and then we set up the
continuous integration stuff now it
would be great if we could start right
there and sometimes you can but again
especially if you're trying to prove
something out it's a little bit
difficult to jump right in then you need
to see what brokes once you did that
then you need to set up your credit
points okay let's do that there and then
redeploy it and see what broke this is
actually what it's like to go back and
forth then we need to talk about
securing that API because I understand
that not everybody shows this and
unfortunately I have mentored many
different interns that were not under my
direct supervision and didn't pay any
attention to securing the API because
they really didn't know what to choose
and where to go with it so we made a
choice for them later on but this is
something that I decided I would show as
well and again there you go and then you
have to really deploy it and see what
row could get okay
then we can create some client access
credentials that you would hand whoever
else wants to consume your API which is
important to understand and then you
test it out then you profit
that is much more like what you'd
actually have to do again there are
micro steps in between these of course
but that's like I think that there's
really like 13 steps to really get
anything off the ground okay all right
so we're gonna combine these two in the
interest of time and we're just going to
create allow we get to create a repo at
the same time with Visual Studio for
those of you who know now I've been
having scaling issues this whole time it
seems like it just doesn't want to stay
that's better that looks more normal
okay cool
all right let's file new that's always
exciting to do all right for this and
I'm going to tell you why in a second
I'm gonna go ahead and just look up
which projects you can use Web API and
in this case I'm going to choose the
dotnet framework version the reason I'm
going to do this is because when we
deploy it after we do the quick publish
when we deploy it to Adger we're gonna
use kudos doesn't even know what kudo is
in the room a couple of you that's
actually what is behind your as you're
publishing tools inside of Visual Studio
except you get to hook into it for a
continuous integration with whatever
repo you choose okay now they'll give
you two options you can do that or you
can do the shiny brand-new Azure DevOps
but depending on your company that may
not actually be an option for you to set
up a whole organization and do all that
if you just really want something that
will throw it out there that was the
reason that Kudo was put together
however if you are doing a full I called
the full framework but really it's just
done it for X right framework you can't
choose the done at standard library here
I thought that was very strange
at least not if you're going to use
continuous integration with Guto because
right now it assumes you're one of the
other you're either dotnet cornets tan
I've gotten a standard or you are full
framing out of the way now right now we
know we that we can go in between but
since dotnet standard is not really
going to be available for 4x you know
once core 3 comes out I'm not going to
worry about it too much but that
definitely took a couple of days
of me figuring out why things could be
published directly from visual studio
but it was not able to be done in
continuous integration okay you guys
follow me cool all right I decided we're
gonna name this the real world guide API
and go ahead and leave it right there
and see I'm sure everybody here is a
master Visual Studio 2017 so I was gonna
leave everything checked there and leave
that checked there okay if you're
interested in anything about Visual
Studio 2019 I just did a blog post about
some settings that you can enable it
kind of gives you a little bit more bang
for your buck out on Octus developer
blog so if you're interested I'll show
you that later okay all right cool
hooray we have one now who here is never
used as your developer tools individual
studio before okay cool the great news
is that's available for you to download
as an extension very exciting I have
already downloaded the extension and
installed it inside a visual studio so
it already knows that those options are
available to me so now that everything's
here I'm just going to go ahead and
right-click on the solution which is my
favorite thing to do and publish so here
I've because I'm signed in if you notice
on the top right I'm already signed in
with my developer account that also is
the same as our account okay so because
they're already connected I don't need
to physically go to the portal at all
for this step I can do it all through
visual studio I want to create a new app
service and it will always you know
prepend the date right after it at the
time if I mostly if it'll do this one
how about
maybe oh it doesn't like that hold on
let me give it that yes cool we are
there all right I've got a set
everything to Europe I'm gonna go ahead
and create that the nice thing about
this is that you don't have to go into
the portal at all and now if you are are
you guys and anybody here from a rather
large company where it DevOps is
separate from development at all
a couple of okay so sometimes like I was
not allowed to do to actually go into
the portal and log in but I was given
access to create new things through this
way or through the azure CLI tool as
well so it depends on what you like to
do most of the developers under me
prefer the visual aspect of Visual
Studio which is why we're not doing
everything command line today but the
only downside to it is that it just
takes a second to do it also I have no
idea how the internet connection is
going but we'll see okay so while this
is pushing out it looks like something's
happening
whoot okay the reason I like to do this
first is because it's instant
gratification and I have no patience so
it's it's really good to know also right
here if anything breaks within your
application you should be able to tell
right away but this is right out of the
box however has any of you ever run into
any issues with the templates that come
inside Visual Studio being outdated at
all because I have specifically around
things like bootstrap or any of really
just any of the JSON stuff it seems like
it's always a few versions behind and
even though I keep my updates on it
doesn't always cut over so sometimes the
first thing you have to do is update
everything but we're not gonna worry
about that right now because it looks
like everything built perfectly this is
exciting so while that is loading out
there I'm just gonna kind of show you
what this looks like in our in our azure
portal boot there we are
there's your app service so I didn't
even have to login to do that but this
is probably old hat to some of you okay
cool so now it looks like
we got here and all the default value
endpoints should be there because that
was the very first thing out of the box
for the API Web API tutorial cool all
right so now that we have all that now
we need to make a change or so so the
first change that I'm going to go ahead
and make is I want to add C all this
just looks so it must be easier for you
to read though huh I'm sorry I just have
no real estate that way okay cool I'll
figure that out eventually in here cool
alright so the first thing I want to do
is I want to add a useful controller do
something useful right I'm going to add
a new controller and this is just going
to be a Web API to controller can be
empty because I've got everything kind
of situated this one is going to be
called a location controller because
what we're gonna do here is simulate
trying to discover where are the events
that the developer advocates for octa
are right now so like I'm here but some
people are in San Francisco and
eventually this API is going to be able
to serve up several applications just
for the location-based data it's going
to hook directly into like our calendar
is both in Google and outlook so that's
the goal of this so this is actually a
real project get to be a part of right
in the beginning and you get this ok
cool so let's just go ahead and do a
basic test
cool all right so now that I made a
change to this I'm gonna go ahead and
fix those usings
now I'm going to connect to team
Explorer right away it shows that I this
right here is the extension github for a
visual studio if you haven't installed
it you don't have to I've used git bash
I've used many other things visual
sourcesafe as well which is a little
deprecated but it's still something I
use so if I want to publish it at github
it'll ask me to it'll automatically
populate if I'm signed in which I am and
publish from there so now that we're
publishing do-do-do cool that should go
straight out to my github depending on
when it gets out there
okay nice to go wait we got it alright
so now that it's out there great so now
we have basic you know source control
that we've got right now what you should
always do I have made the mistake before
I'm proof of concepts to put everything
locally and forget to set this up so
I've just decided now that I make one
change and immediately do it okay cool
so now all right setup CI and see what
broke it sounds like a fun thing to do
oh is it gonna do this every time oh
it's gonna do this every time I'm so
sorry that's alright open for
suggestions alright cool so now that we
have that all situated we're gonna go
into the app service that we just
created and set it up for github okay so
in this case it's this one right here
you're gonna go down to deployment
Center and they were kind of populate
with a couple of different options now
where I came from we used bitbucket a
lot it's anybody here to use that as
well
nope just me okay so everybody else's
github right awesome you're like no we
have some private thing right well the
good news is is that you can do FTP if
you want you know you have lots of
different options you don't have to set
it up through as your repo Shishir where
so we just continue after that suggested
and then here are the two options here
because as your pipelines are still in
preview and they're constantly changing
things that's the reason that I chose
kudu okay cuz it's been around for a
little bit except for the caveat which
you don't want to mix done that standard
with the framework version that you have
okay we're gonna continue there now that
it's gone out because I'm already signed
into the github account so it gives me
two options this is my organization here
on the bottom this one right here is my
for lack of a better word my speaker
account that I like to use so we're
going to use that one
and it automatically populates whatever
repos are out there right so I think the
one that we did is this one I believe
and we're gonna just use the master
branch as our publishing branch okay so
anytime I check anything into that it
should automatically pull it and rebuild
okay all right cool I'm gonna finish
that and as setting up a deployment this
was the very first step where I was like
oh that was pretty easy that's pretty
good if you'll notice in here in a
second it'll it'll show the first bill
that it's trying to do and what the
status immediately was failed this is
the very first one that I saw so
sometimes that has to do with whether or
not you like forked a repo from
somewhere else and then deleted the get
file and then try to check it in there's
a couple of things that could be there
right here obviously the status is
pending right now it's just doing the
initial commit and pull this is a live
window you I've sometimes refreshed
because it seems like depending at right
around ten minutes it seems like the
JavaScript stops working and in some of
you sometimes you have to refresh the
window but in general it should be
automatically just refreshing what
that's pending status is all right so
while it's doing that I'm gonna go ahead
and add something in here that is a
change cool
so looks like that it's still running
that deployment right there what I could
do right now is I could again directly
publish from here and it would override
because I still have the same access to
that app service as a repo so whatever
is the most recent thing is the thing
that gets to be shown and displayed okay
just important to know to not step on
toes that's part of the reason a lot of
people say that once you've done it like
abandon it and go through the proper
channels of making sure that you go
through a pull request and merging in
your branch with master so it can do
this properly but if I were to change
all this it would show but as soon as I
push a change then it would also write
cool it says I have success but because
it may
particularly looked the same as we had
before that's not really proof is it so
in that case I'm gonna go ahead and take
this yes okay I added a location
controller and test cool you're gonna
commit that sink that push all right
well that's pushing I'm really
interested in what testing tools you
like to use for api's I like to use
postman but I've definitely done my fair
share back in the day when I just used
swagger for everything I would also do
that but that required the use of me
actually building the project and
throwing it out there instead of me
doing it this way so what I have here is
I actually pre setup the kinds of
eventually right now we only have one
but eventually the kinds of gifts that I
want to have and we're going to go from
there and also do the rest of the credit
actions so the very first one that I'm
really interested in see if I is the
test so let's get I need to get that URL
here cool all right since I already had
that set up it's just easier for me to
do that and see if I can hit it now I'm
assuming that it's already built it may
not be built but it should be mm-hmm
let's see what it says well looks like
the second one went out there it also
shows the check-in message so you know
exactly which commits you had which is
pretty cool and let's see what postman
did it looks like it just rebuilt but
there you go now we've got our change
this is very gratifying for me I was
very excited to see that this is the
case right so now we've got at least a
true connection a true relationship all
the way up right good awesome so now
let's do something a little bit more
with this if anybody knows how to get
the scaling this day it will be my
friend for life
so what you have that's what happens
when they get a brand-new Mac sorry all
right all right so let's set up our
credit endpoints uh with sadness who's
okay there's no such thing as perfect
development either so okay eventually
I'm gonna get this okay cool
so now let's set up the rest of the card
endpoints I happen to just have them all
here so let's go ahead and do those I'm
gonna go ahead and grab a couple more
and okay cool all right
yes I have a region in there so I like
to do this first because it points out
that I haven't added anything else I
haven't add any of the models that I
want to add in this is also the most
effective way for me to train my junior
developers as to why it's important to
do things in a certain order however I
mean I'm one of those people that
eventually will just add a using this
way absolutely go to it so in order to
do this I decided that I would show like
the separation I'm sure that lots of you
have your opinions about what kind of
architecture you would like to do
there's there's many different kinds out
there for this I just wanted to show
that was popular it was possible to
still publish regardless of how many
projects that you had in the solution
and so we're gonna add a data project
okay do you do do you maybe maybe oh
thank you very much okay
there we go I'm just gonna go ahead and
add a class library
make sure there's lots of templates in
here so I want to make sure I get the
right one
yes cool I'm just going to call it the
same thing real worlds guide dot data
that's what I choose to call it you can
choose to call it whatever you'd like
and there are two models I'm going to
use for here even though I'm only
showing you the location data which is
like the event location that the event
is that eventually I am going to build
all this out so that's part of the
reason that I added more than one cool
all right I'm gonna go ahead and delete
that we're gonna add an event class
cool
[Music]
it just saves me typing time all right
and if he knows there's a list here of
Advocates so I need to add that as well
to this model if you're wondering why
I'm not using keyboard shortcuts it's
because I'm on a Mac and I'm in a VM for
Windows and I have not set up what those
shortcuts are gonna be yet all right
cool
set that up don't worry we're almost
done
cool all right so now that we have both
of those I just need to do a couple of
things I need to make sure that that
builds I'm sorry that one no no you're
good the only thing it's missing is its
reference to the data project now I just
wanted to make sure that the data
project built that I didn't miss
anything
so now that I have that I'm gonna go
ahead and add a reference to the project
would usually populates right away cool
all right so now that that's been added
now I can reference it so oh yes there
we go I guess I didn't name it properly
all the way this is about the time where
I'd be like no we're gonna refactor that
but I'm sure that's boring to you so
that's better
looks like we're only missing a couple
more usings now just a system nut and go
ahead and look at that using a quick
I'll just make sure that that's all good
all right let's just investigate I think
everything looks like it's pretty good
so what I've done here is I did a couple
of static methods right here they just
go ahead and give me some sample data
but if you notice I have especially on
this one right here I have a getter and
setter so this is where we're gonna go
ahead and add additional models in
memory while we are like in postman okay
I decided to just do it for this one so
you could see how it's done but normally
you would hook this up to any database
of your choice using whatever ORM of
your choice for something like what I'm
going to do entity framework is amazing
but sometimes you don't have any say in
the access to the database and you have
to interact in a different way so
sometimes you want to choose a lighter
or m in this case I'm gonna choose
dapper in the future because it's light
enough for that but there are many like
pet apoco as well as great so it depends
on how much heavy lifting you're gonna
be able to really do alright so now
we've got something that looks halfway
decent here hopefully yes okay cool now
let's see if I can just look at the
location all right so now that we have
that I'm just gonna real solution real
quick make sure everything is good dude
you awesome all right cool
and all I'm gonna do is check it in now
all right
okay a data project and you may mean red
endpoints cool all right
I was thinking that pushing it out there
I'm gonna go ahead and start setting up
this to get ready for that so I'm gonna
grab our URL and of course you can use
any sort of cname you'd like if you
would rather have your formalized comm
I've at least for me we always would do
that so that at least we would write
label it okay let's go ahead and look at
getting events here that's perfect
and of course I'm assuming everybody
here has done an API before everyone
awesome so I don't have to tell you how
to do routing so that you understand how
it gets here cool if you're interested
this is also on the github project so
you're welcome to grab it and I'm just
going to check to see how we are doing
it looks like that failed what did it
fail so this is an example of what I
dealt with before right you can look at
the logs for this
and it says that oh it has a default
namespace error it's very frustrating
isn't it so the way that I got around
this before is to delete that data
project and because it didn't like that
class library because if that class
library was a dotnet standard class
library yes
very frustrating so instead what I had
to do is I had to just move them within
the project and it was able to go so
lots of gotchas like bash is very
powerful but it kind of depends on what
you're doing and in your situation right
okay so let's go ahead and move it over
there cool move the event over there and
the Advocate as well
cool alright so now that they're there
let's go ahead and just move that over
all right actually usings that should be
set it's great the other one I think I
have learned more from what is not
possible what is possible it's
interesting okay all right so those are
two are moved over that means we can
officially kill this project project I'm
just going to go ahead and move it there
cool so now that I've moved everything
that means I just have to add the models
or API models namespace there so now
every one of them should still resolve
yep perfect all right so we're gonna go
ahead and rebuild that is it interesting
though it would work here like I would
be able to push that if I were right to
right click publish it would work it's
only just the specifications of Kudo
that would not allow it to do that okay
so that succeeded so we're gonna try
this again and put that in nude models
to Web API projects
cool all right
sink that let's see it see if it does
anything different cool so while that
was prepping this is kind of a little
bit of a preview what you should see
here based on that so just trying to get
everything prepped
I like how fast that does things though
I like how quickly it's able to identify
that check-in so we'll see what it does
yeah this is where you would go and
identify any sort of failure or problem
it's a little bit of an issue though if
you don't run this firm like a tool
yourself that you're able to see the
failure you'd have to have a login or at
least be able to login with your CLI so
looks like that was successful that time
imagine that it usually just takes a
couple of seconds to hit but I'm gonna
see if we can hit it
regardless especially now that the
server is all nice and warmed up all
right
see if we get this
mmm-hmm usually the first time it's all
as though cool alright so there we go
I would pulled everything up nice now
I'm interested though to see if we can't
just make sure to test out you me you
can you can do the deletions and the
puts I'm just going to go ahead and do a
post real quick so over here I'm gonna
just take that one put it back over here
so now instead of this I'm just going to
go ahead and take off the events and
change this to a post put this in the
body I don't know everybody here is
familiar with postman yes anybody not
yeah okay cool I'm in good company good
to know since your raw text for JSON
cool so we're gonna set that tendency
Copenhagen cool I've got a 2-1 created
and just to prove that it actually
worked I just go ahead and change that
back to we get and now it should be at
the bottom okay so we have proven that
we've been able to not just do the gets
but also writing data as well and it was
all done completely through continuous
deployment in Azure awesome great no
sorry I should just just know these all
by heart but okay so now we have to
secure the API right because you don't I
don't want all my data out there I don't
want somebody you're stalking me or
something knowing that I happened to be
in Copenhagen today right
so it's better if the right people have
that information cool so in order for
that to happen
I looked into something that of course
now I work for them but at the time I
did not and I looked into doing some
authentication work via the
almost all right there we go I was
interested in securing things via Owen
I'm sure has anybody used Owen before
okay so you're all security experts this
is probably old hat to you but for me I
need to go ahead and add some
dependencies for that and I have a
little bit of information here for that
these are the four that I need to add I
need a system web based on Owen the Owen
self host for a web api then I'm also
going to need to add the security JSON
web token and open ID connect that's how
we're gonna do all of this okay all
right so everyone's different some
people use the package manager but
everybody at least in my shop really
likes nougat so that's what we're gonna
do all right cool I'm gonna look and
browse for that you guys are probably
the most attentive crowd I've ever had
so this is awesome
okay cool I'm gonna add that and accept
that I'm surprised all this is working
I'm thrilled to death that we have a
good internet Jimmy Bogart was the one
who's like you need to try it it says
it's a thrill to see everything work all
right cool see that one install this one
see I understand that some of this may
be warned some of you but for a lot of
us it was nice to see like what happens
in a row this one takes the longest
annoys annoys me so is copy over the
next when I'm supposed to look for
and it'll change color soon as it's
ready but what we decided to do with
this is I want to secure the endpoints
by putting an authorised attribute on
top of it and Owen is the is the library
that allows us to do that okay so we got
that do do well all right just have to
anymore and then we'll be done with that
maybe oh it's still going there we go
it also gives heart attack because it
looks like it's pretty building it
before all the dependencies are there
it's very strange to see if I can maybe
or not
my poor clipboard
there we go good job cool alright and
just one more I promise cool all right
here we go
I believe it or not we're almost done
all right good deal and open ID Kinect
alright alright so now that we have all
of that we want to create the ability to
secure this and hand over a token
between yourself as the API and whoever
consumes you that you have authorized
right so open ID Connect facilitates
this and depending on whether or not you
want to write your own stuff or wait
until Microsoft includes other
additional things for you to add I
decided to go with what my company does
which is octave so they are the actual
and any provider so they are both ad
like similar to Active Directory but
there also can be the identity provider
for what you need to do so in order for
that to get set up I want to make sure
everything was good here looks like
everything is so far cool just let's
just add that authorized attribute now
that it's available to us cool
the next thing we're gonna do is add a
start up file in order for this to
happen
I'm just go ahead and call it startup CS
and copy this over do
[Music]
cool like I do bhai make sure everything
else looks the same I think so
nice all right so just to you understand
what's happening here is that there's a
couple of things that I'm pulling out of
what would normally be in the web.config
okay the reason I like to use Azure is
because they have app settings that you
can set directly inside of the portal
you can also use the COI tool for this
as well and we can use infrastructure as
a service and and save your scripts to
do this as well but just so that I don't
check everything in with with all of
that I wanted to show you how I was
setting up both who the authority is and
who the audience is and this particular
method is setting up the discovery of
what that configuration is it's pulling
that down and setting up the JSON web
token bearer authentication piece here
and so these two right here are the ones
that are kind of up to you
identity server is another one octa is
one austero is one you can use many of
them without having to write it yourself
but of course you can always write it
yourself so if you're interested in not
doing that let's go into our web config
and I have I think I probably signed out
right but now well I guess I'm not cool
this is the octave dashboard whenever
you sign up for a developer accounts you
get a lot of free usage out of this it's
also forever free it just depends on how
much you want to scale up before you
even would have to pay anything so it's
a lot that's provided to you what you'd
need to do is anytime you create an
application you need to add an
application here okay so what I've done
is I've added an application already all
you had to do is name it and set it up
here and then down here at the bottom
once you have generated an application
inside of Octus portal it gives you the
client ID and secret right here the
other thing that you're going to want to
do is in order for the the client I got
to say this correctly I make sure I say
it's great as long as in order for the
client credentials to flow you need to
set a scope for it okay so if you go up
here to API authorization servers you
get one out of the box that's your
default it has a whole bunch of things
like
and ID already for whatever you just you
have over here like you would set up
like scopes for that particular server
that you needed and by doing that you'd
go over to scopes and I added manage
lists right here
and this is how we would handle a
machine-to-machine situation so whenever
you create a new application you just
create a new socket application and
choose machine to machine because that's
what our API czar right a lot of the
other things will include like a UI for
if you were doing like a like an angular
application it would inject that for you
you wouldn't even even need to create
the login page at all it would redirect
so in this case this just handles the
brokerage of that token for you so now
that we have this couple of things let's
make sure that our web api reflects okay
I'll make sure I've got everything here
here's our app settings cool
so you'll notice like right in between
the app settings that are already in
here I just need to add those two keys
but notice the value is that the value
is set in the azure app setting so
technically speaking if you were just
run this here and not deploy it it
wouldn't work correct but I also don't
want it to work here you can certainly
try it out if you'd like locally but I'm
about ready to check this in okay so I
would like to not do that right cool and
then I'll make sure everything is good
okay you've got everything there I'm
gonna go ahead and build this one time
and we're rolling I still have 15
minutes
this is good all right cool build
succeeded so now that that's all set to
go I'm before I check this in I want to
go into our service and add those two
app settings okay cool um so I'm sure I
have this right
yes okay so down here under application
settings configuration also right
underneath that says preview has it
a little bit differently but they are
basically the same thing it's just a
different view scroll that here and you
will see that there's already one that's
set up you can just add a new setting
right here and I'm just gonna enter the
name we're going to call it audience for
example and then whatever the value was
for this and for that I'm going to go
ahead and swap over to where I stuck
that do I have any questions while I'm
doing this no yes
okay all right then you guys are awesome
[Music]
I'm sorry about that make sure it's
correct there we go so this is what I'm
taking out where'd it go I thought I was
looking at it I guess I was not let me
scroll down for a second manage list
nobody okay here we go so if you notice
right here you could have set the
authority and hard-coded it you could
have put it in the web.config but
instead I want to take out like the
audience which right here is the name of
wherever your authentication server is
which you can see over here in your in
your octo server so if we were to go
back to authorization servers there's
the audience right there so that's what
we need for this so I'm going to go
ahead and set that up right here
cool and add another one which is copy
up here
cool and that is my authority okay I'm
sorry I always do that okay so now
regardless technically speaking I could
just not include this and it would still
work I tried it earlier if I don't like
listed at all in the web.config it still
injects it so I'm but I'm referencing
something in code that a developer would
not be able to follow so for readability
purposes its importance it used to be
that you had to have a representative of
this setting in the web.config but you
don't anymore like it works without it
but again if you were trying to figure
out what is this file that they're
talking about like what is this
configuration right here if they don't
they can't find it so that's the reason
that this is here okay go it also helps
the ghosting problem you're like I don't
know something's happening once I stick
it out and Azure this helps create
parity between the two of them cool all
right now that I have all of that let's
go ahead and check that in I added Oh N
and you're setting big cool anybody
catching anything that I missed no see
you never know I've got a bunch of
awesome people in this room okay so
that's pushing this so we'll see how
that goes but what it should require now
is is that as soon as I hit that end
point again it should tell me that I'm
not authorized so we're gonna do that
first so it looks like that successfully
pushed it let's go back here to the
deployment center and take a look
awesome okay maybe it maybe it will show
us yay
it looks like it's running it awesome I
just want to wait till it's successful
and while it's doing that I should be
able to hit the same endpoint because we
put it at the very top of the controller
I didn't put it on an individual API
endpoint I put it on the whole thing so
regardless of whichever in point I hit
it should tell me to go take a hike says
it's successful wealthy the first one
time I hit it after it builds it always
seems to be a little slow but let's go
ahead and hit it let's see what it says
I'd expect it to tell me no I'm sorry
there are some things now that you need
to do in order to you have to actually
create that generate the token it's cool
but generating the token is the last
thing that we're doing and then it goes
straight into questions yes we have been
denied excellent so now that we've been
denied we have to we need to fix that
whenever you're setting things up for
whoever is going to consume this I'm
going to treat this as if it's going to
be somebody else in my company or like
an actual trusted application and not
here's a public API to hit there's a
different path that you would go through
for that and the generation of the
client IDs and secrets okay this is not
that this is much more for just specific
situations now what if you notice in
enactus portal it already has like a
client ID and secret set up you can also
set up multiple ones to hit this API as
well so that you can say this is the one
for my team this is the client ID and
secret for someone else you can also set
that up if you're interested cool so now
that we set all this up there's a couple
things that we need
do I'm gonna go back to setting up a
post okay we're gonna say and Decius
everywhere cool looks like that's all
setup all right so now everything's set
up here it looks like but you need to go
over to the authorization tab and as
long as you drop this down and select oo
auth 2.0 and set everything up you
should be able to request a new access
token by default set to 1 hour
expiration you can make it as short as
you would like I can also make it as
long as you would like
that's configurable as well but this is
pretty standard especially if you want
to prevent long long living tokens in
the API fashion okay so let's just get
access to a new token this is what it
would look like to put in that those
information okay
as long as they've got the token URL
which is setup usually /v 1 slash token
you can do multiple versions of your
token as well your client ID and secret
I'm just showing it to you here so you
can see it but I'm deleting it so you
can't steal it and make sure to add the
scope manage lists ok this manages the
list of API so that it needs okay and
make sure you set it to basic auth
header ok any questions grant type needs
to be client credentials in order to
fill out these fields we're gonna
request the token now that it has a
token postman is very nice and says
you'd like me to say this free for the
next hour while you're trying to do all
these calls and you say yes I want you
to use the token of course you would
also do this in code if you wanted to go
ahead and call but this at least allows
you to try out as the consumer of the
API what it would look like and any
problems you would have so now that you
have that all set to go now we can send
it and we got a created successfully ok
and just to prove that it really isn't
there let's go ahead
and get that and there we go
hey so we've done quite a bit right we
tested it out and now we profit okay do
I have any questions no awesome so now
that we have built an API in roughly the
steps you would probably need to take
within 60 minutes I assume that you can
very easily go to your other juniors and
mid-level developers and walk them
through this in a day if you have any
questions please hit me up on Twitter
and stay curious thank you
[Applause]